[Musique]
c'est ce qu'on appelle un trop beau qu
alors comme ça vous voulez du quai bing
tandis gaming c'est désagréable bon fort
night part si fort night par la ford ait
juste ici fort night juste l'aref on a
compris à du fort nike partout mais nous
ce qui nous intéresse est trouvée avant
tout le monde le petit jeu qui va
détruire fornas eh ben je crois que je
les trouvais c'est faux mais on va faire
comme si c'était vrai il s'appelle total
il a cure et battle brams et un battle
royale pourquoi le poussons j'augmente à
vue d'oeil je ne sais pas peut-être
parce qu'on en bouffe beaucoup trop
souvent non vraiment c'est ce qu'ont
fait que le premier simulateur de
batailles auxquelles j'avais jeu bref
c'était très sympa alors aujourd'hui on
joue alors [ __ ] de bâtard allez on
commence par créer son perso celui on y
va j'ai pas fait de game encore mais je
crois que c'est juste de la physique
ridicule et tant appréciée de landscape
studio donc samba sow on a un pote ya
six escales mottura calme-toi je me
souviendrai de toi dans la game si je te
croise mon poste est morte la game va
commencer on et 49 au lieu de 100 est ce
que ça veut dire que le jeu marche pas
très bien oui ok c'est marrant tout
pareil comme c'est génial oyez papeete
où on va aller au château ouah j'adore
epic games vous savez quoi copier de ce
jeu en tout cas que vous allez même
copier on est sur une copie snapshot
c'est bon maire de château il est où
ma vue je suis à l'abri des normes il
est où le mec qui avec sa caste je lui
tirait dessus je vais le défoncer au il
est là bas il croit qu'il est seul
discret je suis pas mal je suis pas mort
nous devons faire preuve de prudence
oh [ __ ] ça tire s'avère satire c'est
vers un disque à disque reverra pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai pu mal c'était une blague j'adore
ce que je fais sur youtube une fois
bonne achète c'est génial tout ce que tu
fais surtout la fois au tact et des
mineurs par message privé pour sortir
avec elle c'était vraiment un coup de
génie de tapas bravo aura pas tout du
moins pas au bateau de ton ce caillou
pendant une heure tiens tu répondais
pout un nom team ont atteint satire de
la vie là là ça va durer toute la vidéo
ce duel de merde
oh [ __ ] de manosque ya un an tu vas
mourir à noter à toi il va c'est indiqué
jma s'est retranché tu m'as pas tu m'as
pas j'esquive les balles
ma [ __ ] bon en tout cas c'est une
excellente première game n'est ce pas
allez on y va
au tota tintin tintin oui on vous êtes
foutus
oh là là t'es mort toi on va se
rapprocher on va se le faire alors la
septième année pour nous mais qu'une
pelouse où j'avais pris les lunettes du
pour y aller ce qui se passe tellement
de puissance ça te fait déconnecté
saveur c'est incroyable je me roule est
un peu la moustache et on peut y aller
c'est factuellement vous affectionnez
sportif et moi aussi je marche à pau une
pipe il est rousse qui est lui à toi tu
attends ta ta ta ta ta voilà il fallait
qu'on soit dumbledore pour gagner
maintenant on y va et on gagne cette
partie est ce qu aux caisses parfait
parfait au parfait ordre parfait hunt
lui ne tient et mec c'est l'endroit rêvé
ici c'est le paradis il à vis de moi si
on tue pas un mec dans cette game je me
mets en caleçon pendant mes quatre
prochaines vidéos alors qu'ils tiers on
va calmer le gamin j'ai mis une balle je
vais faire le tour je me dis que tu es
mort bon tir député foutu
au pas
pas un mètre dans cette gamme je me mets
en cassation pendant les quatre
prochaines vidéos pendant les quatre
prochaines vidéos
on va la pécho on va la pécho chanter du
cyril hanouna ça porte chance regarde et
attend la zone à l'est où elle n'est pas
dans la zone
ah ça c'est la zone ça assez des murs
qui se met la violence j'ai un bouclier
à temps mais c'est pas dégueu sans rien
pour sa prochaine un mec alors cousin
c'est baba est regard j'ai préparé un
truc de fou cousin alors vous a fait mal
alors cousin sai baba on va la pécho
cette coupe ou pas suivant table il
campe ou son chien au il est là bas ok
il ya une battle y en a un là des relais
très déçu de cet événement décevant très
de souvent allé bamos n'hésitait pas
être jalouse mais l'une est ainsi
rentabiliser l'investissement moi je me
nourris la jalousie vous savez bien ya
un dauphin
on va aller dire bonjour aux dauphins la
regarde et il est plus un puissant qu'un
poulet aux caps et voilà il va crever
c'est sûr il fait le malin mais il va
crever regardez bien il a écrit la cre
il a écrit alors qu'est ce que tu veux
dire vas-y je t'écoute de bruno herpin
ah ok follow me don't kill me right
watch what you bon ok let's go j'ai
recruté un mec c'est génial viens viens
ma petite [ __ ] marc rubben ont bien fait
rire bien et quand je suis sûr qu'il va
me tuer dès qu'il aura l'occasion
tiens tiens tiens bon
[Musique]
il ne travaille pas il est trop mignon
on a fait une alliance à la la c'est
génial je suis un copain je suis content
et on gambade dans la prairie avec mamie
styles et aux [ __ ] attention ya du
danger mec je veux pas qu'on meure
steuplé jeu qu'on finisse la gamme main
dans la main et qu il restera plus que
nous d'eux eh ben on fera comme dans un
bar gay on se tuera tous les deux allez
viens on y va on y va on y va on a des
couilles on va leur montrer qu'ils sont
les deux meilleurs amis du monde
il est là et jusqu'à est juste là est
juste là juste là où y'a bien jouer
poteau
il ne touche pas encore mon âme au
[ __ ] je vis cette gamme beaucoup
tomberont circuler là bas je les veux
courir
attention attention mon pote attention
copains je t'aime mais fais gaffe tu la
veux tu la veux tu y as compris oulé tia
compris toi on y va on dit pas qu'il est
intouchable
l'eeebox un bug non il est où mon pote
vidéo ce qu'on j'étais perdu non non je
n'ai même pas vu mourir et tous ces
moments qu'on a passé ensemble [ __ ]
alors là ça va chier je ferai pas pour
toi mon pote tu t'inquiètes pas ferro on
va la pécho cette coupe mais [ __ ] j'ai
payé ce jeu 4 euros est ce que c'est bon
je vais faire une dépression sur un jeu
à 4 euros tous ensemble
de ce côté je vous jure je suis en train
de devenir un soir et ce mobile
important depuis très longtemps c'est
normal car il a été supprimé la langue
française lumignons c'est là qu'on se
sent bien à claquer dès qu un peu la
claque est dès que monsieur il ya un mec
au dessus je les ai vus heureusement ce
jeu est nul et bugs
ah bah non c'était un lit mais c'est une
vraie mine d'or tabarnak tout un cac à
toi mon pote ou c'est quoi ça ou aimait
qu'on va faire top a enfin
ok oh [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] je te
passe bien acheté buzz
a pas d'endroit grenade sports dont j'ai
crié le maître quitter
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] il m'a vu obtient cheminée
elle va m'aider il n'est pas aussi bon
que moi mon pote on à l'actuel de sniper
la phase iib j'y vais j'y vais j'y vais
j'y vais j'y vais un moment faut y aller
mais que je stresse on est plus que 11
j'ai besoin il ya que lui et moi quoi
entrer dans la vie pourquoi moi
je m'en fous je lâcherai rien tant qu'il
n'y a pas de taupins sur ce jeu auquel
personne ne joue pas squeeze il se
nourrit et son chien non plus
la prenons à l'instant le troubadour
squeeze et son chien là dessus ont été
retrouvés en état de décomposition
avancé devant un ordinateur
l'ordinateur va bien son compère cyprien
cherche donc un remplaçant pour leur
chaîne commune
si vous êtes intéressés vous pouvez le
contacter sur son nouveau numéro 07 59
en tout cas je trouve ya du progrès par
rapport à tout à l'heure
cette musique l'ambiance on va faire
taupin en mode russe égaux alors la
mecque j'ai tellement bien téméraire ça
c'est pourquoi ça c'est pour lui c'est
qu'il t'aime lui tuer comme ça c'est
qu'ils baissent de merde go te fais
comme jamais gouaille à personne j'ai
plus l'habitude schwarzenegger dans tous
les terminators réuni est-ce que ça va
un mec cool n'est pas content mais c'est
tellement de game over
on va à la pêche on sait tous on est
plus que 12 mon petit pas et ça ça me
fait plaisir
[Musique]
on se retrouvera encore de [ __ ] t'as
pas être apportées n'en est plus qu'à
bordel de merde
savvis plus mal qu'un bulletin de chiens
veuf assaillants n'est plus que trois
soirs là là la pression que tu es vite
oh [ __ ]
non
il est trop chaud lui
j'y crois pas je n'y crois pas oh well
done fait je devrais me sucer la [ __ ]
michael est de ton lecteur cd c'est tout
ce que tu devrais faire je suis vulgaire
j'en peux plus ça fait trois ans que tu
là dessus il a pissé là bas il lui a
faim et tous ses amis c'était plutôt
simple finalement un petit bilan de ce
jeu il est très sympa il a était gratuit
pendant quelques jours sur steam donc à
plein de gens qui l'ont téléchargée il
ya 1800 joueurs en ligne on est loin
d'un pdg odin fendrik mais franchement
c'est vraiment sympa et c'est pas du
tout ça [ __ ] je croyais que c'était
simple trop lol mais il ya des mecs qui
ont trahi hard petit point faible c'est
très mal optimisé les serveurs sont un
peu claquer des fois t'es déconnecté
sans trop de raison mais franchement
c'est certain pour un petit jeu à 4
euros ce sympa je suis très heureux
d'être faite au pain même si c'est dans
deux les connaisseurs auront vu que le
mec que j'ai tué c'était le seul qu'il
de ma game et ces gens là je leur
réponds et alors
et alors qu'on soit caché dans un
buisson ou pas pendant toute la gamme le
résultat est le même j'ai fait top 1 est
ce que tu as fait top un toit banon je
vais enfin pouvoir prendre mon char
souleva et le nourrir ainsi que la l'été
ainsi que le faire à l'été c'est parti
bébé monde et vous allez à bientôt en
tuant la famille je vous aime bisous ça
veut dire
[Musique]
mais tu as cru j'allais faire sortir un
truc de derrière la porte à chaque outre
aux bisous
[Musique]